oppression makes a wise man mad your
fathers were wise men
and if they did not go mad they became
restive under this treatment
with brave men there's always a remedy
for oppression
those were the words of frederick
douglass from his famous july 5th speech
spoken by his descendants
but it's another anniversary being
celebrated on this day 175 years ago
when douglas arrived in ireland just
seven years after his escape from
slavery he wrote his memoir and hoped
to connect to a nation who supported his
cause
that legacy is something his family
still celebrates
when i opened it for the first time and
looked down
those eyes twinkled at me was like you
finally found me i've been waiting for
you
nettie douglas was introduced to her
great great grandfather through this
drawing
ireland made such an impact on frederick
douglass
she's reminiscing a lot these days as
she reflects on the journey that changed
everything
sometimes it's hard for me to say this
so sometimes i tear up
it was the first time in his life that
he was not looked at because of his
color
he was treated as a human being where he
said people actually looked me in the
eye
addressed me as mister he was urged to
leave the united states fearing
recapture
following the publication of his memoir
the narrative of the life of frederick
douglass
an american slave it's frederick
douglass aged
27 which is the age he was in ireland
irish historian and quinnipiac
university professor christine connealy
has been researching douglas for a
decade he believed that his four months
in ireland
changed him from being just an
abolitionist into somebody who respected
the rights
and fought for change for the oppressed
people everywhere
so he himself saw his time in ireland as
transformative
why was he so taken with the people you
know irish people are very famous for
their welcome
but what also i think happened to
frederick was he was so surprised by the
poverty of the irish people
and by the center irish people had been
colonised for 600 years
and he said you're not slaves but you
are oppressed
and you are impoverished and you are
marginalized catholics in ireland were
persecuted under british colonial rule
they were prohibited from buying land or
voting
that ended with catholic emancipation in
1829
an accomplishment largely due to the
efforts of political leader
daniel o'connell daniel o'connell saw
him as an equal
invited him to come and speak alongside
him
the fact that when he was in ireland
they reproduced his narrative for him it
sold out they reproduced it again
frederick is now taking ownership of his
life
story frederick is gaining agency about
how he wants things to be done
daniel moho ireland's ambassador to the
united states
first heard of douglas through his
relationship with the father of irish
independence
douglas had had been very impressed by
o'connell's
political uh philosophy which was
non-violent agitation to achieve
political reform
how do irish people today see him well i
think it
it kind of runs through the um civil
rights movement in the united states in
the 1960s
[Music]
[Applause]
which influenced the civil rights
movement in northern ireland but i think
the connection today also is the fact
that
because of the black lives matter um
movement here in the united states
people in ireland have started to think
about um the changes that have occurred
in irish society
we now have a multiracial multicultural
society that's why i think the frederick
douglass story
resonates strongly with ireland today
president barack obama's visit in 2011
put an
exclamation point on that philosophy
when he traced his ancestral roots to
county awfully
now i knew that i had some roots across
the atlantic
but until recently i could not
unequivocally
claim that i was one of those irish
americans
but now there's no one more irish than
me
by some estimates there are 38 percent
of
african-americans who have some irish
ancestries cleveland native dennis
brownlee is one of them
he founded the african-american irish
diaspora network
to further explore afro-irish american
history
i found that a lot of this shared
ancestry came
not just from the oppression of slavery
but also through
the shared communities that existed and
consensual relationships
what future do you see coming out of
this
well i think in the times that we're in
it's important for
all of us to look at all ways that we
are more alike than we are
different a discovery douglas made
himself
through a journey some say returned him
home a more enlightened soul
and that was the great thing about
frederick he didn't just fight to end
slavery
he fought to end social injustice he
believed in the dignity of labor he
believed in women's suffrage
so he truly was international and
universal in his message
whose teachings still ring true today
one of my favorite expressions
frederick douglass is agitate agitate
agitate
those three words were arguably
douglas's most famous and nettie told me
that he actually
got the first agitate from daniel
o'connell
so really an amazing connection there
and
the fighting spirit must run in the
blood of the douglas family because
nettie is taking it a step further
fighting for huma fighting against human
trafficking i should say through
the frederick douglass family initiative
so she
and her siblings and her cousins
are continuing the fight in his name
human rights amazing story michelle
thank you